ADAM EIJDENBERG: Thank
you, everyone,
for coming this morning.
Clearly the party last night
mustn't have been as good as
the night before, because we
have a lot of people here very
early in the morning
for an auth talk.
So thank you for coming.
My name is Adam Eijdenberg.
I'm a product manager on our
Cloud Platform Team.
This is my colleague Ben.
BEN WILEY SITTLER:
I'm Ben Sittler.
I'm an engineer on our
authorization and
authentication team.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So before we
get started, maybe just a
quick hands up around
the room.
Who here gets really excited
about authentication?
Really?
I was going to let you in on a
bit of a secret, which is that
I don't actually get as excited
about authentication
as I do about using the API
that I'm trying to access.
And I think one of the things
I really want to do today is
show you how easy it is to
be able to get past the
authentication step when using
Cloud Platform and get to
using one of the 60 or so APIs
that Google provides.
So when I look at a Cloud
platform, I see we have a
number of different areas.
We have services and APIs that
we provide that make it easy
for you to get on with
solving your problem.
We have services like Cloud
Storage, which is an object
[INAUDIBLE].
We have Cloud SQL.
We have Cloud NoSQL.
Two different ways of storing
data and manipulating that
from within your application.
We have things like Big Query,
which is a great way of
manipulating huge amounts of
data and running query and
getting [? business ?]
intelligence out of that.
But now I look, and I see a
second half of what we have.
We have a number of containers
where you can write code.
We have App Engine, which is
the platform as a service
offering, and we have Compute
Engine, which is our
infrastructure as a
service offering.
App Engine lets you write code
and automatically take care of
scaling that and building a
great web application for you.
Compute Engine gives you virtual
machines, so you can
write your own code and
do it your own way.
But what we don't see on this
diagram-- and it is a very
pretty diagram.
It came from our marketing
department, and they actually--
I actually learned a
new word this week.
They called it a marketecture
diagram, and that was a new
one for me.
But what we don't see on here
is, I think, the glue that
holds this together, which
is authentication and
authorization, which is how
you identify the code that
you're running to the rest
of Google services.
So whether you're running your
code within our platform on
App Engine or Compute Engine,
or you're running your code
under your desk, or whether
you're running it on premise
or if you're running it on
another service provider.
And so what we're going to
go through today is the
authentication part.
How to identify your code to
Google so that you can use our
APIs and you can get on with
building the application that
you're trying to [INAUDIBLE].
Now, we say auth a lot, and
auth can mean a lot of
different things to
different people.
I split into two areas--
authentication and
authorization.
So authentication, to me, is
knowing who you are, whether
that's a person logging into
an application, or whether
that's your application
making a call
against one of our APIs.
Today, we're going to go
through, we're going to show
you how to write code to
authenticate against our APIs.
We're going to show you easy
ways to do it using our client
libraries, but we're also going
to show you how to do it
from first principles.
So if you're not using one of
our client libraries, and you
actually really want to
understand what's going on
behind the scenes, we're
going to show you
how to do that, too.
We're going to look at how to
do that from within the App
Engine, within Compute Engine.
We have some special tricks
there that make it very easy.
And we're going to show you how
to do that from anywhere
else, whether it's under your
desk on premise or on another
hosting provider.
The second part of auth that
we're going to talk about is
authorization.
And authorization--
I always think of that
as the second step.
Now we know who you are.
Are you allowed to perform
the action that
you're trying to do?
So are you allowed to start
this virtual machine?
Are you allowed to read
this particular
file in Cloud Storage?
We're going to spend some time
on that today, but we're not
going to spend as much time.
The authorization part is
primarily configuration.
It's not as complicated.
There aren't as many spots that
you can go wrong there.
But what I want to show today
is how to set that up and go
through some of the common
pitfalls I see when people are
trying to do this and when
they're having difficulty
accessing our APIs.
So I thought maybe first, let's
look at what goes into
making an API call against
a Google hosted API.
The good news is, we host all
of our APIs in the same spot
at Google, which means that once
you figure out how to do
this once-- once you master this
in one spot-- you can hit
any of our other APIs
the same way.
So let's look at, say,
the Big Query API.
So those of you that don't know
what Big Query is, it's a
way of uploading a huge amount
of data-- gigabytes, hundreds
of gigabytes of data-- into
Google, and running big
queries against those SQL-like
statements to get
results very quickly.
I'm not going to focus on what
Big Query does, but what I am
going to focus on is how to
make an API call that.
And with Big Query, one of the
primary entities that you
operate on are data sets.
You upload data sets into a
project that you own, and
those are resources that
you then manipulate.
So let's look at an API call to
list the data sets that I
have associated with
the project.
All of our API calls are HTTP,
or more accurately, HTTPS.
And when we make that API call,
we either do a get or a
post or another type of
HTTP verb, and we
specify a number of things.
We specify the API that
we want to hit-- in
this case, Big Query.
We support multiple
versions of APIs.
So here, we're accessing
version 2 of
the Big Query API.
The rest of the path that we
have here will vary a little
bit by service.
But a fairly common pattern we
see within the Cloud Platform
Services is we're manipulating
resources
that belong to a project.
So typically, you would see the
word project somewhere in
that path. then you'll see an
identifier for that project
and that path.
In this case, I can see project
number 1, 2, 3, 4, and
I would try to list
the data sets
associated with this project.
We go against a common host--
the googleapis.com server.
And now, the interesting bit.
We have this authorization
header, and that header is all
we need to get right.
That passes in what we call a
bearer token, and that's a
token that will then allow us to
access that particular API.
So the focus today in our
presentation is going to be
how to acquire one of those
access tokens so that you can
make that API call, because
the rest of the API call's
fairly simple.
It's basic HTTP.
Again, we have client libraries
for it, but we're
going to show you how to do it
from first principle as well.
So let's look at what one of
those tokens is to us.
We call it an access token
behind the scenes, and when I
think about access tokens, to
me, this is very much like an
HTTP session cookie.
You go through some kind of
dance to set it, we return it
back, and then you staple that
to each of your requests that
you send to us.
And when we get one of those
access tokens, we look up,
essentially, three pieces
of information.
We authenticate we know
what application is
associated with this call.
What that means is that when you
want to make an API call
against Google, you first must
register the application that
you're building.
Now, application doesn't mean
an Android app or a web app.
This could just be a process
running under your desk.
But you register an application
as that
application that is
making that call.
We also refer to that fairly
synonymously as the client
that is associated with
that request.
The second bit of information
that we have associated with
the token is a user.
So when you're making a request,
you may be making it
on behalf of a user, or the
application might be
acting on its own.
And I'll give you an
example of that.
Let's say that we're accessing
Google Drive.
Google Drive is a consumer
product, but we have APIs go
through the same infrastructure
so that you can
register an application, allow
the user to click through a
consent screen, and then your
application can access their
data and their drive.
And so that's a case where you
have a client that is acting
on behalf of a user.
That's not the typical pattern
that we see in Cloud.
In Cloud, typically you are
building applications.
You're building that on top of
our platform, on top of our
infrastructure.
And you might have your own set
of users, you might not
have any users, you might just
have an application that is
doing analysis with Big Query.
So in this particular case, for
a typical Cloud Platform
API, your user is your
application.
One and the same thing.
The third bit of information
that we have associated with
an access token is one
or more scopes.
When you get an access token,
it's not an all powerful being
that lets you do anything
against any API.
When you get that access token,
you request that we
downscope it to let
you perform a
certain set of actions.
So, for example, when we had
the user clicking through a
consent screen to access Google
Drive, they're not
authorizing your application
to access their Gmail.
They're only authorizing your
application to access the
Google Drive content.
And in the same way, because we
use the same architecture
within Cloud, when you get an
access token to talk to Big
Query, if you accidentally leak
that token, you can't
just magically use that to start
virtual machines in a
project, unless you requested
virtual machine scope when you
started at the same time.
So how do we get one
of these tokens?
This can vary depending on whose
data is being accessed.
Again, the first case where
we have user data--
how do we get that?
We register an application, we
write some magic code, we pop
up a user consent screen, the
user consents to allow you to
access the data on a certain
spot, and you get back an
access token.
I'm not going to talk through
that in any detail today.
That's not going to be
the focus today.
We have a heap of sessions on
Sign In with G+, which is
built on top of this same behind
the scenes flow, and we
have a lot of other resources
there that I could
point you to later.
What I'm going to focus on today
is how to help you build
your application on top of Cloud
Platform, and how to get
an access token for your
application, where there is no
user present to agree
to a consent screen.
You need a way of getting
credentials so that your
application can then talk to
Google and access APIs to
manipulate your data.
So there's two parts to this.
The first part is we need to
create a project and do some
configuration.
I'm going to go through
and talk about that.
Then we get to the fun bit.
Ben's going to then show us how
to write some code to use
the data that we've configured,
and to make that
successful API call.
So the first thing we
need to do is we
need to create a project.
And a project is an entity that
basically represents your
relationship as a developer with
Google for the context of
what you're trying to do.
So when we create a project, I
think of this as a container
for a number of things.
It's a container for resources
that will belong to y our
application.
So, for example, if you're using
Cloud Storage, you'll be
creating buckets.
Those buckets are associated
with a project.
That project, ultimately, will
get the bill for the usage of
those buckets.
Similarly, when you create
virtual machines, they're
associated with the project.
When you upload Big Query data
sets, they're are associated
with the project.
So one key part of what a
project does is access a
container for the resources
that belong to your
application.
The second key part to what a
project does is this is where
you register an application that
wants to make an API call
against Google.
And those API calls
aren't limited to
Cloud Platform resources.
Any of the other 60 APIs that
Google provides goes through
the same common area.
So this is where we will
register our application.
This is where we will get
credentials that we can then
use to make subsequent
API calls.
There's also a bunch of other
configuration that lives
within a project.
We have information there about
billing, if you're using
a service that requires
payment.
We have information about quota
that may be set up,
either a free quota, or you
can actually specify and
configure a per user quota for
individual users that are
using API on your behalf.
We also track here-- this
is also where you enter
authorization information.
And I'll go through that
in more detail later.
But essentially, this is where
you can create a team.
A project is not tied to
an individual person.
That's not typically how
developers operate.
You have other developers that
you're working with.
You shouldn't have to share
passwords to log in to manage
a common set of resources.
So this is where you can add
your teammates to your project
and work and collaborate
together.
So we created a project.
We gave it a name before.
The next thing we need to do
is we need to enable these
services that we're interested
in using.
So here, I'm enabling the
Big Query service.
Now, I should just note, this is
the current what we call a
developer console that we're
looking in through today.
We have another console that I
think you might have seen some
other screenshots of this week
if you've been through some of
the other Cloud Platform
sessions.
It's called the Cloud Console.
These are essentially
equivalent.
The same functionality is fairly
much present in each.
Cloud Console is what we're
moving towards for Cloud, but
it's still not quite has all of
the authentication things
that we're going
to show today.
So that's why I'm still
using the old UI.
If you do use the new UI to
create a project-- and I do
actually recommend doing that,
because it has a nice tie-in
with Google App Engine
that we can talk
about in detail later--
you can still click back through
to the developer
console and see that data.
It's stored in the same spot.
You can manipulate with
either user interface.
Let's keep going.
We've enabled the service.
Now we need to do
something called
create a service account.
Now, let's think about what
happens when you run a process
on your local workstation.
You log into your operating
system as a user, and when you
start a process, it's associated
with your user ID.
What that means is that when you
try and, say, open a file
from within your application,
your operating
system will do a check.
It knows what file you're trying
to access, it knows
what user the application is
running in, and then it does a
check to make sure that the user
ID has access to the file
that you're reading.
Now, if you were to deploy that
same application into a
production environment,
typically you wouldn't run it
as your personal account.
You might set up
a role account.
Let's say you're running
Apache in production.
You might use the Nobody
account on a box.
So when you run that
application, you
assign it an identity.
You might use pseudo and
[INAUDIBLE] and swap it and
run it out as a Nobody user.
Similarly, when you access a
Google API, we need to know
who your application is.
The user ID associated
with the process--
that doesn't mean anything to
us, when you're accessing
across the internet
to our services.
So instead, what we have you do
is we have you assign your
application a service account.
And a service account is very
similar to a role account.
It's our way of knowing who
your application is.
So we have a couple of
different ways of
setting this up.
We have some neat tricks
[INAUDIBLE]
App Engine, but right now,
we're going to create a
service account that has a
private key that we can then
download and put into our
application to access APIs.
So the very first time we click
through this flow, we do
get prompted to enter some
branding information about our
application.
This is really useful if we were
accessing one of those
APIs like Drive API, where we
need to pop a consent screen
up to users, and they need to
see some information about who
is this crazy app that's trying
to access my data?
This is completely irrelevant to
the Cloud Platform in terms
of service accounts.
So skip this screen, fill in the
[INAUDIBLE] field, which
is the name, and
then continue.
Service accounts, they don't
get consent screens.
There's no human associated
with it.
There's nothing for them to
click, so just ignore this
screen and move back on.
So now we have an opportunity
where we can select what type
of client are we creating, or
what type of application are
we registering?
And here, if I was doing one of
the consent driven flows, I
might pick a web application.
Because I want a service
account, I want an identity
for my application.
We hit service account, and
then we generate a public
private key on our service.
We throw away the private
key component.
Well, we don't throw it away.
We let you download it, and
then we throw it away.
We just then keep the public
component off that.
We give you a file that
you download.
This is essentially your
password, or your credentials
that you'll use when you access
our services on behalf
of your application.
We do actually encrypt.
We use a PKCS12 format, which
is an encrypted private key
format, and it has a password
of notasecret.
So don't tell anyone, but write
that down, and we'll use
that for the next step.
When we create that
service account--
they never take screenshots of
my username that I've created
on my service account here.
But we get an email address
associated with that as well.
And that email address, again,
is not a human user.
Don't try and add that
to your G+ posts.
They don't post very often.
But you do need to take note of
that email address, because
when we try and set access
control up later, we use that
email address to represent
this is the user that I'm
trying to access, even though
that user is an application.
There are also some options
here for rotating
that private key.
You can create a new one.
So if you do accidentally lose
that private key file, you can
create a new one here, and
then disable the old one.
So we talked through how
to configure a project.
We set a project up, we've
created a service account,
we've download a private key,
we have an email address
associated with it, and now
we're ready to use it.
I'm going to hand off to Ben,
who's now going to show us how
to write some code to use
that service account
to access an API.
BEN WILEY SITTLER:
Thank you, Adam.
So let's get an access token.
Now, remember that we have an
email address that represents
our surface account-- our
application's identity.
We also have an API we're
trying to access--
in this case, Big Query.
And for each of the Cloud APIs,
there's typically a
scope, or two different scopes,
for the API-- a full
access scope and a
read only scope.
For Big Query we'll use
the full access scope.
Now, to actually get an
access token, we need
to create an assertion.
To do this, we created a JSON
object, which describes who we
are, what we're asking for, and
who we're sending this to,
and how long the assertion
is good for.
We need to make sure that
someone can't take this
assertion and replay it later.
We then JSON encode this, base
64, URL safe encode it, strip
off the equals signs,
and sign it.
The signing uses the key that
Adam showed you earlier, with
the password notasecret.
So in this case, we're going to
use the open SSL library to
sign it, reusing RSA to sign
and a SHA256 signature.
And once we append that to our
earlier assertion, it's ready
to send to Google.
So we send this to
accounts.google.com, and this
assertion gives us back
an access token.
It looks like this.
Or rather, we get a
JSON object that
includes an access token.
This, you may notice,
has an expires_in.
This access token, if someone
else intercepts it, will only
be good for them for an hour.
Of course, you should be using
SSL everywhere, and make sure
that no one can intercept it.
But regardless, at the end of
the hour, you'll need to get
another one.
So go ahead.
Store this in your mem cache.
Share it across the instances
of your application.
Create multiple of them
if you need to.
Now, let's use this.
To actually access the API, we
would like to put that access
token we just got into the HTTP
authorization header.
This is fairly straightforward.
We access our project's
big store data sets,
and we get back this.
Not very exciting, but that is
not what you were looking for.
You were looking for working.
Now, this can be even easier.
We have client libraries
for a variety of
platforms and languages.
Here, we're going
to show Python.
And in this case, we still need
those same three pieces
of information--
your service account's email
address, its private key, and
the API scope we're
trying to access.
We use the
SignedJwtAssertionCredentials
class, and we use this to
authorize an HTTP object.
Now, you may wonder what's
going on here.
What this will give us is an
HTTP object, as you may
already be comfortable
using in Python.
But unlike other HTTP objects,
this one is wrapped and sends
along that authorization header
automatically with
every request.
So what do we get back?
An HTTP object we can use
to access that same API.
And indeed, we get back exactly
the same answer.
Perhaps a boring, but
it works, and
that's what you want.
Now, we also have something
called the discovery API.
The discovery API gives back a
JSON introspection for each of
the API versions that
Google publishes.
We have not just Cloud APIs.
We have a wide variety
of APIs, as
Adam mentioned earlier.
But for all of these APIs, this
discovery API returns the
methods, the parameters, and
how to encode the requests,
and how to read back
the responses.
In this case, we are looking for
the data sets API from Big
Query, and in particular, we're
looking for the list
method with the project
ID mentioned earlier.
And note that once you call
that list method, you're
getting back a request object.
But nothing has actually been
sent to a server yet.
For that, you need
to call execute.
And here is where special
HTTP object comes in.
When we call execute, we pass in
our decorated HTTP object,
and this means the request
will be executed with the
authorization header.
Indeed, response is as before.
Now, we also have Google
hosted environments.
I'm sure you've all heard of App
Engine and Compute Engine.
And we can make this
even easier.
Remember earlier, we had three
pieces of information.
Adam's going to tell you more
about how we use this.
ADAM EIJDENBERG:
Thank you, Ben.
So what Ben's gone through and
shown us is how to use that
private key that we created
before, and how to then use
that to generate what we call an
assertion, and then how to
sign that assertion with
that private key,
send that to Google--
now we have an access token.
We're ready for business.
Once we have that access token,
we can hit those APIs.
We can do exactly the same thing
in Compute Engine and
Google App Engine.
The neat thing about Compute
Engine and App Engine is they
are already running on Google's
infrastructure.
Because they're running in
our data center on our
infrastructure, we know
who they are.
We can prove that that app is
your app, and that app is
belonging to another project.
We know this.
And so what that means is that
we still use a surface account
to access APIs, but we use a
surface account that has built
credentials.
So what that means is that
when you start a Compute
Engine virtual machine, you can
tell it to use a surface
account, and here are the
scopes that I want.
And then from within that
virtual machine, we can make
access tokens available directly
to your application
without ever needing to
see a private key.
And exactly the same
with an App Engine.
When you create an App Engine
app, we create a service
account associated with that App
Engine app, and then you
can use that.
You can add that to access
control lists for other
services and other projects,
and then you can get access
tokens for that straightaway.
And so Ben's going to now
show us how to do that.
BEN WILEY SITTLER:
Thank you, Adam.
So let's start with
App Engine.
Now, before, remember, we
needed three pieces of
information.
We needed the email address for
our service account, we
needed a private key, and
we needed an API scope.
Only the last one
is needed here.
We use the App Identity API
to get an access token.
You notice we did not
sign an assertion.
We didn't have to make
an HTTP request to
get our access token.
This is all handled for
us by App Engine.
Now, our client libraries
also make this easy.
You can use the app assertion
credentials class to get the
same effect, and this gets you
back a decorated HTTP object
very similar to the
one we saw before.
In fact, we can do
the same thing in
Google Compute Engine.
As Adam mentioned, you need to
tell Compute Engine which
scopes your VM is allowed
to access.
So in this case, we're
going to let instance
foobar access Big Query.
To fetch a token in
Compute Engine is
actually an HTTP request.
We can talk to the metadata
server and get back an access
token, just as before.
Now, once again, you can use our
client libraries to make
this even easier.
We have an app assertion
credentials once again, but
this one's from the
oath2client.gce package rather
than for App Engine.
And it gives you, likewise,
an HTTP object, which is
automatically adding
authorization headers.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So Ben showed
us a number of different ways
to get those access tokens from
him, but all we need is
one access token.
That's all we need to actually
access an API.
And I think we've gone through
three different ways.
We have doing it from first
principles, we have using part
of our client library--
the oauth part
of our client library.
And that oath part-- it gives
us those HTTP objects back.
And to me, that's probably
my favorite part.
We have these special HTTP
objects that's like an HTTP
object with benefits, right?
I can use that object the same
way that I'm used to making
regular HTTP requests, but it
automatically adds that
authorization header for us.
And even better, it'll
detect when my access
token is going to expire.
It'll get me a new one.
So I don't have to write code
in my app to do that for me.
In addition, if for any other
reason, the access token
doesn't work, it'll get a new
one for me automatically.
So I think that's a really
powerful way of taking
advantage of being able to use
those client libraries to
access our APIs, even
if you don't use
the rest of the stack.
Even if you don't use the full
discovery API as well, which
is also a very useful part of
the library, especially when
you're getting started with an
API and you're trying to learn
about what the different
methods are that exist.
So when we run an application,
we assign
it a service account.
We give it an identity.
That's how we do it.
We can use built in credentials
in App Engine and
Compute Engine.
But when you're running
elsewhere--
and this includes when you're
doing local development with
App Engine, where we don't know
who your application is,
because it's running on
your workstation--
we give you the downloadable
private keys that you can then
associate with your
application to
give it that identity.
So that's kind of the first part
of the presentation on
authentication and how we
authenticate your app, where
we need to write code
to do that.
The second part, I'm going to
talk a little bit about
authorization and how to
configure your project so that
once you know who your
application is, we then let it
actually proceed with
the request.
And what I'm really going to go
through is just sort of hit
off on a couple of points on how
we process that request so
that if you get an error back
saying access not configured
correctly or similar, you know
what steps to do to fix it.
So if you remember before,
our access token--
three main parts.
The client that's making the
request, the user associated
with the request, and the scopes
that are associated
with the request.
Now, let's see how
we use those.
Now, primarily the authorization
is done
based on the user.
We look at the user associated
with the token, we look at the
resource that they are trying to
access, and then we look at
the project associated with
that resource that they're
trying to access.
And then we make sure that that
user is on the team for
that project.
Different services have slightly
different semantics
for what the different roles
in a project mean.
I'm showing the project team
page up there right now.
We have can edit, can
view, and owner.
Each service has a slightly
different interpretation of
what those mean, but generally
the edit can write objects,
the read can view objects,
and owner can do
anything to those objects.
Some services, like Cloud
Storage, let you go a little
bit deeper and set access
control entries on individual
objects and individual
buckets.
But essentially, they default
to these parameters here.
So the first thing you want to
do is make sure that the
object that you're trying to
access-- that the project it
belongs to has the application
on the team.
And that's done automatically
for service accounts that you
create within a project.
But if you do you create an
App Engine app, and then
separately, you create a project
in the developer
console, they are different.
So you will need to get the
email address associated with
that App Engine service account
and add that to the
team in the developer's
console.
If you use the new Cloud
Console, a lot of that's
handled automatically for you.
We then look at the scopes
that are in the request.
So once we figured out that the
user is allowed to access
the object, we then check to see
what scopes are associated
with that API call.
And if you don't have those
scopes associated with that
access token, we won't let that
request go through, either.
So make sure that you request
via the appropriate scope with
your access token.
And those scopes can be found in
the documentation for each
of the APIs.
The second part is based
on the client.
So we do most the authorization
based on the
user, but there are a bunch of
other things that we do based
on the client.
And the client, remember, that's
the application that
you register with Google.
And there's a few things
we check there.
And they're not strictly
authorization, but I call them
out here, because you'll get a
very similar error message
back if it's not configured
correctly.
First, we make sure that the
service that you're trying to
access is actually enabled
in the project.
And the project that we're
concerned about there is the
project associated with the
client that you created.
So when you create a client that
belongs to a project, you
need to make sure that the
service or the API you're
trying to access is turned
on for that project.
If it's an API that requires
a credit card or a form of
payment-- some do and some
don't-- you need to make sure
that that billing is enabled
and set up on that project.
And we also will do checks
against quota.
You might see a quota error come
back from time to time.
And that can come back primarily
for two reasons.
Some projects will have a free
quota, and then after that,
it's paid, and maybe
the billing
information isn't set up.
And we also have the ability for
you to be able to specify
a per user quota.
The per user quota here is
probably more useful when
you're building an application
using, say, a drive API or a
calendar API, where you have
individual users who are
accessing data using
your application.
And then you can configure
a per user quota
that gets set up there.
I just mentioned this.
These are places to check.
There's a quotas tab in
the developer console.
These are places to check if
you're having any errors
accessing the API.
And finally--
and this is fairly specific
to Cloud--
all of these checks are
generally based on the project
associated with the credentials
of the client that
you've created.
When you're accessing a resource
that belongs to
another project, we check
in both places.
So if you have project A and
project B, and you have an
application registered here and
a resource in Project B,
we'll do the checks
in both places.
So make sure [INAUDIBLE]
set up.
A lot of the use cases
we see are
typically within one project.
I just mention that
for completeness.
So to finish off, to access any
of our APIs, you need to
give us an access token.
We use service accounts to get
those for Cloud resources, and
then make sure that that
user is authorized.
Make sure it's added
to the right team.
Yeah, we have a fairly active
community in our developer
relations group, and others
watching Stack Overflow.
That's a great spot
to ask for help.
If you're struggling to access
an API, come and ask for help
there, and we will try
and help you out.
And I think what I'd like to
finish on saying is, I don't
think successfully
authenticating an API call is
the exciting part of being a
developer on Cloud Platform.
I don't think that's
that exciting.
To me, what is exciting is being
able to get past that
step and get to those APIs and
start building my app.
Because if you're stuck for
three or four hours trying to
authenticate, that's a lot of
wasted time, and I don't think
it's that interesting.
Once you get past that, once
you get that successful API
call, I think that's a
really good feeling.
But even though you and I might
not be that interested
in the authentication part,
at Google, we're lucky.
We're a big company.
We have over 250 full-time
engineers whose job is to work
on security, and their job is
to work on security of your
data in our data centers.
And they care about this a lot,
and they spend a lot of
time and effort on
these details.
When I first started using some
of our APIs, I kind of
felt there were a lot of
hoops to jump through.
It kind of seemed
a bit strange.
I had to download these private
keys, and create these
assertions, and send them off,
and get access tokens back.
But what I discovered was,
talking to people like Ben,
talking with people on our
security team, is that each of
those hoops is there for a
reason, and most of those
reasons are actually
good ones.
And that once I could convince
myself that there's no magic
actually going on in the
client libraries, it's
actually a pretty simple flow
to make those requests--
once I figured out, hey, now
I understand it, I get it.
Now I'm just going to use the
client libraries, and use
those to make my calls.
And once you get that API call
done, you're an auth ninja.
And the best thing about being
an auth ninja on one of our
APIs is there's then another 60
different APIs that you can
go out and try, and you've
already figured out the
hardest part, which
is authentication.
So thank you very much
for coming out today.
We've got a couple minutes now
for Q and A. Ben and I will be
around outside at Cloud Platform
Sandbox afterwards.
We also have--
I don't know if Ryan Boyd is
in the audience right now.
Ryan has just written a book on
oauth, and I think he might
be doing book signings
a little bit
later there as well.
So, any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A couple over here.
One is around the concept of
a client versus a project.
I'm still not quite clear in
terms of their relationship,
whether it's a many to many
relationship, or it's a parent
child relationship.
That's first.
And then the second part of it
is around token management.
Is there any facility provided
by Google that allows me to
deactivate or invalidate
a token that I've
given up in the past?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: OK,
so I'll answer the
first part of the question.
I'll defer to Ben
on the second.
I see the relationship between
the client and the project as
parent child.
See, clients belong
to one project.
A project may have multiple
clients as children.
And Ben, on the token
management?
BEN WILEY SITTLER: So anytime
you have an access token, you
can send it to our standard
OAuth 2 token verification
endpoint, and it will stop
working after that.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: You can
also wait one hour.
Yes?
BEN WILEY SITTLER:
Can you come to
the microphone, please?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Just because
the session's being recorded.
I know we have a lot of folks
that aren't in the room today.
AUDIENCE: Supposing if I'm using
your OAuth token, but I
also want to implement a two
level, like sending the code--
like how Gmail does it--
the code instantly,
whenever I log in.
If I want to put that also
in my application,
what I should do?
Like, the instant code,
I get it, right?
Supposing if I have a two level
authentication, I have
the user name and
then password.
Afterwards, I'll ask for
the code, you know?
So the Google sends me the code
through SMS or something.
So if I want to put also
in my application,
how should I do it?
Along with OAuth, what
should I do?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: So I think what
you're talking about is
probably what we refer to as
two factor authentication,
which, by the way, if anyone
here does not have two factor
authentication set up,
set it up right away.
It is a fantastic way to keep
your account secure.
And if you don't know what two
factor is, what it is--
normally, when you log into a
Google account, you give your
email address and a password.
What two factor does is once
you put your email and
password in, it will then send
you, either via an SMS or via
an app we have on Android,
a six digit code.
And you need to put that in.
You only need to do about
once a month or so.
It can be a little bit
frustrating that once a month
when you do it, but on the plus
side, if someone gets
your password-- because
maybe you've reused
it somewhere else--
then they can't actually
access your account.
Now, back to the question
in terms of how does
that relate to OAuth?
So for the service account use
case, it doesn't apply at all.
The service account just
has a private key.
It's your application.
For a more traditional--
let's say I'm using a Google
API to access.
Let's say we're using
the Drive example.
You're building an application,
and you wanted to
access a user's data.
This is actually one of the
great things about using OAuth
instead of taking the user's
username and password and
sending it on.
You do a redirect back to a
Google screen, and what that
means is that all of the
functionality that's on the
regular Google login screen is
available to the user that's
entering their credentials.
They'll put their username and
password in if they're not
already authenticated in
the browser window.
Then they'll have to go through
two factor, if they
haven't already done
that recently.
Then they all see a screen
saying, hey, this app wants to
access your drive data.
Allow or deny?
When they hit allow, that will
then send an authorization
code back to your application,
which you can then use to
exchange and get an
access token.
And we didn't cover that flow
today, but hopefully, that
answers that question.
Sorry, a question
on this side?
AUDIENCE: Adam, thanks.
I'll try to be as concise
as possible.
I'm going to imagine
an imaginary app
that I want to make.
Let's say I wanted to have a
Chrome extension that did
something like take the URL or
something, put it up on your
Drive, of whoever's
logged in there.
So like you had just said for
the previous one, there's the
client side authentication to
say which Google Drive are
you, if you're not already
there, and then
it gives you that.
But for this project that I
have, let's say I go through
and I make the project
for myself.
I enable it for Google
Drive Service.
I create a Service account,
and I generate a
private key, then.
And then I can, at run time,
get an access token to use.
It all works great.
I put this up as an extension,
and millions of people
download it everywhere.
And then all of a sudden,
now I've got
problems with the quota.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: [INAUDIBLE]
millions of people with access
to your private key.
AUDIENCE: So is there,
I guess, maybe--
is there an API that we can have
for generating these API
tokens so that every single
person who downloads the
extension can have their own
token, let's say, for
themselves as a developer,
when they're really not
developers, but that way, they
have their own quota for every
person that downloads it?
I'm not sure if there's
an API for these APIs.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: It sounds to
me like that's probably more
of a case for what we call the
three legged authentication
flow, where you have the
user consenting to
access their data.
In which case we don't
use the private key.
We don't need to generate
a private key.
We'd probably use--
and I should probably defer to
Ben pretty quickly here.
I was going to say web
application flow.
Do we have something special
for Chrome extensions?
BEN WILEY SITTLER: I think
Chrome extensions--
AUDIENCE: Well, I just
made that up.
Let's just say it's not
a Chrome extension.
It's an executable that I make
freely available, and they
download that there.
But it would be the same
question I have, is how does
that throttling happen when
it's just out there and
everybody's using it
for their own?
ADAM EIJDENBERG: I can give you
a very concrete example.
So if you look at gcutil or
gsutil, and those are
utilities that Google provides
for managing Compute Engine
and Cloud Storage
respectively.
That's a binary, essentially,
that we distribute.
And when you download and run
that binary-- and by the way,
it's using all of
our public APIs.
But when you run that binary,
the user is presented with a
URL that's opened automatically
in the browser
for them that allows them to
consent to manage their cloud
storage objects or their virtual
machine objects on
their behalf.
And that, then returns,
actually, what we call a
refresh token, which is like an
access token, but it's one
that we can use to get more
access tokens after an hour
when it expires.
You would then store that
locally on their machine, and
then you can use that to
make subsequent calls.
And that's when those per user
quotas come into effect.
So that's where you can then
throttle users-- make sure
that one user doesn't ruin it
for everyone else by doing
thousands and thousands
of API calls.
AUDIENCE: But if someone does do
that-- like, what if there
is people who then use this new
thing you've made and you
can't guarantee that other
people who've downloaded it
won't have had the quota taken
up by someone they don't know.
ADAM EIJDENBERG: Yes.
So it actually is a per user
quota that you can set.
So you can set it so that each
user might only be able to do
10 requests per second, or
some limit like that.
So I think we're running
out of time.
I'm getting the get off the
stage signal from the back.
Please come and find us after,
because we're going to be
around until about 10:30 at
the Cloud Platform booth.
Thank you, everyone,
for coming today.
If you did enjoy the session,
if you do want Ben and I to
come back next year and tell you
more about authentication,
please write the session at
the back, and there's a
feedback QR code over there.
If you didn't like the session,
if we just wasted 45
minutes of your time, no one
reads the feedback, so don't
worry about it.
Thank you.